beaucoup beaucoup de lettres dans le
courrier des shadoks l'autre qui
proviennent partout monaco dans ce
courrier il ya quelques lettres qui
s'égare j'ai 12 ans veille si possible
répondre à la question suivante à quoi
sert cet instrument je les ai eus en
achetant une trousse qu un instrument en
question
seconde question pourquoi la misère de
chez moi ne pousse pas alors que je la
rose comme il faut cela fait presque un
mois que je lai qu'elle est toujours
dans le même état
à quoi sert cet instrument est bien cet
instrument ne sert pratiquement à rien
mais peut n'être utilisé par
avantageusement pour remplacer la misère
justement qui ne pousse pas comme c'est
vers les fixes et toujours bien propre
alors prenez le pot de l'isère pour
retirer la misère qui ne bouge pas et
vous planter sa à la place offrant un
joli plan
y at il une loi comme quoi nous n'avons
pas le droit d'avoir des animaux
domestiques chez nul n'y a pas de loi on
a parfaitement le droit d'élever choix
des animaux je me suis dit si on élève
des animaux domestiques du lait comme le
vin par exemple il faut demander une
autorisation spéciale à l'administration
pour pouvoir exploiter les animaux
domestiques par son salon n'a pas le
droit de 13 et 15 ans je déteste les
shadoks sas est catégorique je suis
devenu une téléspectatrice kitty que les
shadoks sens pour les attardés mentaux a
alors est ce vraiment oui ou non les
shadoks sens pour les attardés mentaux
nous allons savoir tout de suite car
voici justement la soeur d'un petit car
franck dans ce cas là cette demoiselle
nous écrit j'ai un petit frère qui est
malheureusement a retardé mais qui parle
bien et qui sait ce qu'il dit quand il
voit les shadoks idées qui sont faux et
il fait le geste avec son doigt sur la
tempe
cet idiot les shadoks même pour les
attardés mentaux là on voyait ça c'est
un test important qui nous ouvre de
nouvelles perspectives doit d'ailleurs
savoir si c'est un peu éclairé nouveau
quel geste fait au petit frère quand il
se regarde dans une glace
arriver à faire vivre des recoupements
pourquoi avoir supprimé les lettres
majuscules des noms propres dans
l'émission gorille le diable nos enfants
s'étonne qu'un plat sont les réprimandes
quand elles sont omises
et cela fausse leur jugement oui
vous avez raison madame je reconnais que
supprimer les majuscules dans la tête
que de très mauvais goût mais vous savez
que dans le cadre de la réforme
culturelle et de la région d'éducation
nationale on cherche à décentraliser le
plus possible et on emmène maintenant
très souvent les enfants dans les musées
ou y voir un certain nombre de monuments
vous remarquerez qu'on novelis clockers
ne comporte dans les hiéroglyphes aucune
majuscule dernière lettre et dernière
question en quoi consistent les shadoks
est-ce bien instructif pour les enfants
de leur parler de bateaux de l'espace
vous avez effectivement il n'est
peut-être pas très instructif pour les
enfants de leur parler des bateaux de
l'espace mme pendant des années des
années on leur a parlé de la ligne
maginot où la lune le nez rouge théâtre
nous